Saben, cuando Chris me ofreció hablar en TED, dije que no
que creí que no iba a ser capaz
de entablar la conexión personal que quería.
Es una conferencia tan grande.
Pero me explicó que él estaba en un aprieto,
y que le estaba costando encontrar el tipo de atractivo sexual
y el estrellato por el que la conferencia es reconocida -
(Risas)
asi que dije está bien, Ted - digo, Chris. Iré bajo dos condiciones.
Una - quiero hablar lo más temprano posible.
y dos - quiero elegir el tema para TED 2006.
Afortunadamente aceptó. Y el tema, en dos años,
será: "Lindas Fotos de Cachorros."
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Yo inventé la Camara Placebo.
(Risas)
En realidad no toma fotos, pero es mucho más barata,
y aún así sientes que estuviste ahí.
(Risas)
"Estimado Sr, Buen día, saludos y mis mejores deseos
a ud. y su familia. Sé que esta carta le resultará sorpresiva,
pero no deje que sea una sorpresa,
ya que la naturaleza tiene una manera de llevar sin ser anunciada,
y, como el refrán dice, los originales son muy dificil de encontrar,
pero sus ecos suenan fuertes. Así que decidí ponerme en contacto con usted,
para que ud. me asegure seguridad y honestidad,
si debo confiarle cualquier monto de dinero bajo su custodia.
Soy Mister Michael Bangoora, el hijo del difunto Mister Tiamu Bangoora -
(Risas)
quien fue el Ministro de Francia en Sierra Leone -
(Aplausos)
pero fue asesinado durante la guerra civil.
(Risas)
Sabiendo que su país es una inversión economica favorable,
y que su gente es transpatente y confiable en los negocios,
bajo dicha premisa le escribo.
(Risas)
Antes de la muerte de my padre,
él tenía la suma de 23 millones de dolares estadounidenses,
que mantuvo lejor de los líderes rebeldes
durante el transcurso de la guerra.
(Risas)
Dicho fondo debía ser utilizado
para la rehabilitacion de las reservas de agua del país,
antes del estallido de la guerra. Cuando la guerra estalló,
el líder rebelde demandó que el fondo le fuera entregado,
my padre insistió que no lo tenía bajo su posesión,
y fue asesinado por negarse a entregar ese fondo.
Mientas tanto, mi madre y yo somos los unicos que sabemos de dicho fondo
porque me padre siempre confiaba en mí.
Rapidamente hice un arreglo con un trabajador de la Cruz Roja,
que usó su camioneta oficial para transportar el dinero al Aeropuerto Lungi, en Freetown
aunque no conocía el verdadero contenido de la caja.
(Risas)
El fondo fue depositado como respaldo familiar,
en una compania de seguridad confiable en Dakar, Senegal,
donde se me proveyó solo asilo temporal.
No tengo deseos de invertir el dinero en Senegal
debido al clima económico desfavorable, y tan cerca de mi país.
La unica asistencia que necesito, que sé que haría ud. por mi,
son las siguentes: una, ser un socio silencioso
y recibir los fondos en su cuenta a credito;
dos, proveer una cuenta bancara bajo su control
a la cual los fondos serán remitidos
tres, recibir los fondos en su cuenta a credito,
restar su comisión y dejar el resto del dinero
hasta que yo llegue, cuando la transferencia esté completa.
Sinceramente, Mister Michael Bangoora."
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Esto es verdaderamente embarazoso.
Me dijeron detrás del escenario que tenía 18 minutos.
Solo preparé 15.
(Risas)
Así que, si les parece bien, me gustaría esperar por 3 minutos.
Lo lamento mucho.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
¿Cuál es su nombre?
(Risas)
Mark Serfaas. Eso es muy cool, no? Persiguiendo la felicidad.
¿Eres virgen? ¿Virgen?
(Risas)
Quiero decir - digo, en el sentido de TED?
¿Lo eres? ah, si. Entonces, ¿qué eres,
como 1000, 2000 ahí? eh? oh?
¿No sabes de qué estoy hablando?
(Risas)
Ah, Mark -
Serfaas.
(Risas)
1860 - ¿estoy bien?
Y eso no es nada para avergonzarse.
No es nada de qué avergonzarse.
(Aplausos)
Si, estaba con algunos tipos de Google ayer a la noche.
Con mucha onda, nos estabamos emborrachando.
(Risas)
Y me contaban que el software de Google ha avanzado tanto
que, basandose en tu interacción con Google durante tu vida,
pueden predecir qué vas a decir a contiuación.
(Risas)
Y yo decía, "Vayanse al demonio, eso es una locura."
Pero dijeron: "No, pero no le muestres a nadie", pero se les escapó.
Y dijeron que yo podía escribir "que voy a decir a continuación",
y mi nombre, y me diría. Y debo decirles, ahora,
esto es un software puro,
es un navegador de Internet real, y este es el sitio real de Google,
y lo vamos a probar hoy en vivo.
¿Qué iba a decir a continuación? Y Ze Frank - ese soy yo.
¿Me siento afortunado?
(Risas)
Audiencia: SI.
Ze Frank: oh, increible.
(Risas)
En Marzo del 2001 -
Me filmé bailando la canción "Justify My Love" de Madonna
Un Jueves, mande un link a una página web
que presentaba esos clips a 17 de mis amigos más cercanos,
como parte de - invitación a mi - una invitacion a mis tr..
tr - 26 años.
(Risas)
Para el Lunes, más de 1 millon de personas
entraban al sitio.
(Risas)
A la semana, recibí un llamado de EarthLink que decía,
que debido al costo de 10 centavos por megabite extra,
les debía 30.000 dolares.
(Risas)
De más está decir, pude dejar mi trabajo (fui despedido).
Y finalmente, saben, ser independiente (desempleado).
(Risas)
Pero algunas personas se refieren a mi - más como un guru de Internet o - (un idiota)
swami (Perdedor).
(Risas)
Yo - yo sabía que tenía algo.
Bascamente había destilado una filosofía muy dificil de explicar
y compleja, en la que no me adentraré aquí,
porque es muy profunda para ustedes, pero -
(Risas)
is sobre lo que hace populares a los sitios web, y, saben, es -
(Bailar como un idiota y no vender nada) - (Risas)
es una lástima que no tenga más tiempo.
Quizas pueda volver el año que viene, o algo así.
(Risas)
Estoy obsesionado con el e-mail. Recibo mucho.
4 años más tarde, todavía recibo 200 o 300 por día
de gente que no conozco, y ha sido una oportunidad increible
de conocer diferentes culturas, saben?
Es como un microscopio al resto del mundo.
Uno puede como mirar la vida de otros,
y siento que me da mucha inspiración
del usuario promedio.
Por ejemplo, alguien me escribió.
ecía, "Hey Ze, si alguna vez venis a Boulder,
deberías 'rockearla' con nosotros", I dije, "Por qué esperar?"
Y dijeron, "Hey Ze, gracias por 'rockearla',
pero me refería all tipo de 'rockeada' en la que estaríamos desnudos."
(Risas)
Y eso fue embarazoso.
Pero saben, es una colaboración
entre mis fans y yo, asi que dije, "Dale"
(Risas)
Oigo a muchos de uds. murmurando.
Y sé lo que están diciendo. Dicen "A la mierda,
¿cómo es tan fluida su presentación?"
(Risas)
Y debo decir, que no soy todo yo este año.
Supongo que Chris debe llevarse algo de crédito, porque en años anteriores
Supongo que ha habido algo así como oradores de baja calidad en TED. No lo sé.
(risas)
Asi que, este año, Chris nos envio un simulador de Conferencias TED.
(Risas)
Que realmente nos permitió, como oradores, llegara las trincheras,
y practicar en casa, para estar listos para esta experiencia.
Y debo decir que, saben, es realmente genial estar acá.
(Aplausos)
Quisiera contarles un pequeño chiste. Pero no es solo lo bueno.
Puedo poner el modo "interrupciones molestas"
Voz: Hey, idiota, sal del escenario.
ZF: Tú sal del escenario.
(Risas)
Voz: Queremos a Malcom Gladwell.
(Aplausos)
En caso de que te pases de tiempo.
Yo - una sola cosa que quiero decir, yo, realmente -
(Risas)
quiero agradecerles a todos por estar presentes.
Y modo rana.
Ah, la primera vez que le hice el amor a un camarón -
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Es cierto. Algunas personas me dicen,
dice, Ze, estas haciendo todas estas cosas, cosas en Internet,
y no estas ganando nada de dinero.
(Risas)
¿Por qué? y yo digo, "Mamá, papá -
lo estoy intentando." Saben, no se si se dan cuenta de esto,
pero el mercado de videojuegos,
los chicos estan jugando estos videojuegos, oh, que se yo
pero, se supone que hay mucho dinero
Digo, creo que, como 100.000 dolares por año aproximadamente se gastan
en estas cosas. Así que decidí probar suerte.
Se me ocurrieron algunos juegos.
(Risas)
Este se llama "Ateo."
Calculo que sería popular con los niños pequeños.
Miren, me muevo, digo algunas cosas.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Entonces eso no funcionó tan bien.
(Risas)
No entiendo por qué se rien.
Deberían hacer hecho esto antes de que intente venderlo.
"Budista" por supuesto, se ve muy parecido a "Ateo."
(Risas)
Pero vuelves como un pato.
Y esto es genial porque, saben, por 25 centavos,
puedes jugar este juego por un largo tiempo.
(Risas)
Y Chris me había dicho en un e-mail que,
deberíamos traer algo novedoso a TED,
algo que no hayamos mostrado a nadie.
Así que preparé esto para TED. Es "Cristiano"
Es el tercero de la serie.
Espero que le vaya bien este año.
(Risas)
¿Tienen alguna preferencia? Buena elección.
Entonces pueden esperar a la resurrección - (Risas)
que es -
(Risas)
un numero al azar entre 1 y 500 millones.
Entonces, en verdad, ¿de qué estamos hablando? ah, disfrute tech.
(Risas)
El Disfrute tech, para mí, significa algo,
porque disfruto mucho de la tecnología.
Y, de hecho, hacer cosas usando la tecnología -
y hablo en serio aquí, aunque esté usando mi voz sarcastica -
No lo haré - esperen. Hacer cosas, saben -
hacer cosas me da una mucha alegría.
Es el proceso de creación que me mantiene, como
una burbuja y media sobre la ansiedad perpetua de mi vida,
y ese es el sentimiento de haber completado el 80% de un proyecto -
cuando sabes que todavía tienes algo que hacer,
pero no está terminado, y no estás empezando algo -
eso llena mi vida completamente.
Así, lo que he hecho fue, comenzé a interesarme
en crear espacios online para compartir ese sentimiento
con personas que no se consideran artistas.
Estamos en una cultura de gurúes. Es tan dificil usar algunos softwares
porque son inaccesibles,
la gente siente que tiene que leer el manual.
Así que yo intento -
(Risas)
trato de crear estas actividades mínimas
que permitan a la gente expresarse y, ojalá -
wow, estoy - en la pagina, pero no existe.
(Risas)
Es como - en serio -
Trato de crear ambientes significativos
para que la gente se exprese
(Risas)
Aquí, cree un concurso llamado "cuando los elementos de oficina atacan"
el cual, creo, realmente resonó con -
(Risas)
la población trabajadora.
Más de 500 ingresos en 3 semanas, "Moda de papel higienico"
(Risas)
Nuevamente, gente de todo el país haciendo -
el reloj es especialmente increible.
(Risas)
Herramientas para dibujar online - seguramente vieron muchas de ellas.
Creo que son maravillosas.
Me parece que es una oportunidad para que la gente pueda jugar con crayones
y ese tipo de cosas. Pero me interesa el proceso,
el proceso de crear, es el evento que me interesa de verdad.
Y el problema es que mucha gente apesta para dibujar.
y se desaniman ante esta, saben, figura de palitos,
pequeña y horrible cosa que crearon.
Y eventualmente, hace que dejen de jugar con eso,
o dibujar, saben, dibujan penes y cosas así.
(Risas)
Entonces, el Scribbler es un intento de crear una herramienta generativa.
En otras palabras, es una herramienta de ayuda.
Puedes dibujar una figura simple de palitos, y luego ella colabora
contigo para crear, algo así como, un grabado alemán post-guerra.
(Risas)
Entonces puedes - de hecho, está ajustado para ser mejor dibujando cosas
que se ven peor. Entonces, adelante, empezamos a garabatear, y -
la idea es que puedes realmente,
sabes, tomar parte en este proceso,
y observar cómo algo feo puede verse hermoso.
Y estos son algunos de mis favoritos. Esta es una pequeña marioneta
que me fue enviada. Ahí está, muy bueno.
(Risas)
Divino. Es algo hermoso.
Digo, esto es increible. Esto lo dibujó una niña de 11 años
y lo envió. Es simplemente hermoso.
(Risas)
Estoy hablando en serio. Realmente - esto no es un chiste.
Pero, creo, es - es algo muy divertido y maravilloso.
Esto se llama el Proyecto Ficción. Es un espacio online,
que es - basicamente un foro restaurado
que fomenta la escritura ficcional colaborativa.
Estos son haikus.
Ninguno fue escrito por la misma persona,
de hecho, niguna linea lo fue -
saben, cada linea fue contribuida por una persona diferente
en un momento diferente.
Creo que el "ahora atada arriba y abajo,
amante cruel se me acerca, atada, arriba"
Es - es una manera increible, y les digo,
Si llegan a casa y su pareja, o quien sea,
les dice "hablemos" - eso los deja congelados hasta los huesos.
Pero las actividades perifericas, como estas,
que permiten que la jente se reuna, hacer cosas divertidas.
Realmente llegan a conocerse,
y son estas actividades perifericas, de bajo umbral las que creo son la clave
para aumentar nuestro capital de lazos sociales
que nos falta. Y muy, muy rapidamente -
amo los títeres. Aquí hay un títere.
Baila con la música, Lotte Reiniger,
una increible presentadora de espectaculos de sombras de marionetar en los '20,
que comenzó a hacer cosas más elaboradas.
Me interesé en las marionetas,
Y quiero mostrarles una ultima cosa.
Oh, así es como se hacen las marionetas.
(Aplauso)
Chris Anderson: Damas y Caballeros, Mr. Ze Frank.
(Aplausos)